これでいいだろうということなどことなど
はいえー今から自分の日本語のおかしいところを紹介してみたいと思います
紹介してみた二紹介してみたいと思います h man
ラギをが全体的におかしい特にぶー
るまあよく文を持ってる持ってる
思っている
っていう感じじゃなくて思ってる思ってる
若干こうしたが後ろに包んで包んで僕がこの音でも飲んでる時にしたを後ろに英公
動かしてから
前にこの横の動きをするんですって
襲われたんですけれどもおかしいんですよねまあ日本人だったらこう普通にここ
死刑って悠々と思うんですけど歯茎にこう軽く当ててこの音音音を作ると思うんです
けれどもこうしてしまったら英語の
あーノートなっちゃうから僕を意識的に長いあるがこうしてしまったから今でも正しい
発音がわかっているのになかなか a 直せないというか2番
a あのあのっていうつなぎ言葉を言う時はよくへ
アンニョンって言っちゃうことです3番アクセントも全体的におかしい
全体的におかしいという表現を使いすぎているっていうのが a 4判で3番
富3番
アクセントも全体的におかしい例えば3番じゃなくて3番ということなど3番じゃなく
て3番っていうことなど3番じゃなくて3番ということなどことのことをよく
ことと発音すること5番
じゃなくて5番口もねもうちょっと開け開けて話した方がいいと思うんですよね日本語
の上ボーイ
本員はホントあいーぷオっていう感じてこうきれいに言わなければならないんです
けれども僕はよくまぁこんな感じで言っちゃうというかあんまり高はきれいな発音で
しないっていうか全体的に日本語の
暴飲をきれいに言わなければならないんですよね綺麗に言うべきです英語はそうでも
ないんですよねっていうのはまあ蔵王のダクシンと言ってエアー苦戦つが来ている
本以外の暴飲を全部あ
と発音してしまう現象がええけん以降が特にアメリカ人にありますしかし日本語には
この現象
この現象がないので僕を含めて多くのアメリカ人英語を母語とする外国人
よく巻取ればん
不安走るの端るっ走る
派じゃなくてはっって言うんですよね派じゃなくてはっって言うんですよね
で何でかって言ってその言葉のアクセントが
しに来る来るからなんですよねだから獣化は大切じゃないって思い思い込んでいるって
いうかで
走る走る走るまぁこれでいいんだって思っちゃうこそ人が多いんですけれども
はぁじゃなくて走るこれ
抹茶日本語だったら抹茶って言うじゃないですか両方の棒銀をあ綺麗にあっって言うん
ですけれども
パッ英語だったら最初の正
兄アクセントがきてるんですよね抹茶
で最初のボーイにアクセントか来ることで来てるからー
その後にクレイ後に来るふっくる
暴飲がえっ
あじゃなくなっちゃうんですっていうのはあがぁあ
になるんですよね抹茶まーまーちゃ
r アーチャー mature todos os と japanese フォン
グリーンティーのローズ
抹茶ネイルペディキュア rbd アーム賞金抹茶を baboon aba bar
m グリーンマーカーパターと母へ
人の方方とかを
a
買ったとか言っちゃったりとか結構真面目な話のちゃっ
ごめんなさいこんな感じだと思いますけどまぁこのほかにもね
おかしいところものすごくたくさんあるんですけれども今日は a
まあ僕が普段から意識的に直そうと思っている自分の日本語のおかしいところを言って
みました
前回の動画結構皆な皆さん
me
ni